look one thing we should establish from
the get-go ricky let's do that
is i i like things in moderation
right if you're too far to the right
fringe i don't [ __ ] with you
if you're too far to the left fringe i
don't [ __ ] with you yeah i like to keep
things in between the 40s as if our
friend
tigram beckham is listening this is
something we talk about all the time
keep it between the 40s maybe you move
the ball a little bit to the left maybe
go to the right
anyone that's hanging on the goal post
like people who used to maybe be on this
show
right i can't get down with i'll call
out an aoc
just like i'll call out a uh
uh anyone on the right who's uh no
rubio's not all the way to the right
right
bruce isn't all the way to the right no
but uh who is all the way to the right
who is all the way to the right that i
mean that's a good question who is
actually all the way to the right
on the uh louis gomer from texas louis
gomez all the way to the right he's very
far no
hold on hold on hold on let's talk about
who's far right that actually has a
voice aoc has a voice
omar has a voice listen she's playing
the game bernie sanders he's playing the
game bernie sanders says
he's playing the game who has you can't
get mad at people
from the right you have a strong voice
and a strong opinion he's a writer that
people are listening
that's not what i'm saying my question
is who is influential on the right that
is far right
influential not somebody some person
that you know that everybody on
watching us has to go look up you don't
have to look up aoc everybody knows who
aoc is
she's playing the game okay i get that
but what i'm getting what i'm getting at
is that who's so far radical fart right
that has a that's influential
who's far right that's influential it's
actually a very good question
who's very very far right a a i think uh
well-known figure that's on the that's
far is lindsay graham
far right lindsey graham no i don't
think he's very far is he a voice for
i think our friend donald trump had some
far-right tendencies that
he is not very far right especially
socially
maybe um he's got some authoritarian
qualities
but he brings out people on the far
right so the authoritarian or he just
was speaking for the americans that are
tired of the bs
which one is this a little bit of both
well listen
by the way if you're watching this help
us out here who would you say is the
person that's who's the most
somebody said ben shapiro but he's not a
politician he's not a politician
i wouldn't say because he called that
trump as well who would you put as far
right
politicians as a matter of fact ben
shapiro in 2019 or 820 was
the number one target of the all right
so you can't the alt right or the
alt-right
right isn't even far right they're
they're off they're often worse yeah
that's even worse
so that's what i'm getting at ben
shapiro was cr he didn't even vote for
trump in 2016. like a david duke and not
that he's uh
he's a he's uh but i'm getting it i'm
getting at the
sauces that you have to dig for those
people and they're not even big
known figures the far left has a lot
mitch mcconnell
i don't think i don't think any of these
are extremely far right by the way that
makes a very good point by the way
because if you think about it let's put
a chart right okay you got in let's just
put a chart here
okay i'm gonna put the line here in the
middle this is a
simple independent person okay
i'm gonna put the libertarian here okay
i'm gonna put the libertarian here i'm
gonna put the
democrat say here okay let's put
socialist here okay let's put communist
here is that fair
yes okay let's put republican here
and then far right here
okay all right where would you say if we
say this is the independent
right in the middle okay libertarian we
got plenty of that right rand paul is
one of them
let's put rubio let's put cruz here yes
republican let's put trump here yes okay
i agreed
where do you want to put obama obama's
here or you put him a little bit here
uh i would put him in the middle between
democrat and socialist okay where do you
put biden
uh he's he's i i think he's a democrat
i think he plays a role
100 socially between socialists and
communists sanders
same thing who do you put over here
there's nobody big figures
like jeff sessions there yeah jeff
sessions who's that
john
jeff sessions was does not have a voice
does nothing
i'm talking about my grandmother ann
coulter's very far right yeah
okay so now see how about this this is
the comments that's coming up candace
far right candace owens she's right but
not far right no
got it it's interesting it's interesting
to see
well thank goodness that there's not
people very very very far right that we
can't
i'm thankful of that you know what's
crazy people think that far right is we
want our gun rights
right we were pro-life right no they're
pro-life
pro-life believing i always find it in
liberty but i'll kill you if you
don't know how is that how is that far
right
it's crazy that everything's got pulled
so to the left you can look at
regular conservative values are not far
right you know like if it was some type
of
nationalist type thing you know it's
insane so who's far right i'll tell you
it's so loud it seems like it's far
right
trump's ear what's this guy's name steve
um bannon
steve bannon uh breitbart a little bit
but there was also the other guy
the bald guy um jesus what's his name
the fact that you're thinking an
immigration not a big man
you have your you have your the the
grassroots yeah it's crazy
let me explain to you what i mean adam
people that are
here think that this
is the middle and it's steven miller
steven miller people that are here
think that people are here are far right
i don't mean
between democrat and social media
republicans
it's not yeah so to them if you go the
line is
here independent yeah the left has
pushed the left the line right
where are you that this is where they're
at where are you on this chart i'm 100
republican conservative aware on this
chart
if you had to i'm right here this is
where i'm at 100 percent
where are you that's another penny he's
always said that well i don't want to
speak for penny
i'm i'm a registered independent but i'm
probably more here libertarian because
to me
to me it's uh uh let me see that go
ahead okay
you're you're here you're saying i'm
right he's here yeah yeah
i'm somewhere around here on certain
things but fiscally
i'm closer to now i don't think you're
here i think you're here
i think you're to the right of democrats
i don't think i think you're your
mansion i think that's exactly that's
who have i been saying for a year that
is like my favorite politics i think
that's who you are
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye you